Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
It's great to welcome to the program today,
Katherine Eban, who is an investigative journalist
and Fortune magazine
contributor, as well as the author of bottle
of lies, the inside story of the generic drug.
Boom.
Catherine, so great to talk to you today.
Thank you so much for having me on the show.
So generic drugs is an issue that relates
to intellectual property.
It relates to FDA regulation, it relates to
the medical world.
I mean, there's so many different areas that
are relevant to talking about generic drugs,
but I, I guess to begin with, how far back
does the concept of a generic go?
Well, I mean, it really goes all the way back
to, uh, probably the 1920s, 1930s.
But the idea that, um, you could, you could
basically be a company that breaks down a
brand name drug and tries to remake version
of it is a very old concept
in the sort of modern generic drug world.
When we look at generic alternatives to name
brand drugs, many people believe that it is
down to the finest level, the exact same thing
as the brand name, except without the brand
name.
It turns out that, that that's not always
true and it's in fact often not true in ways
that are sort of concerning and dangerous.
Talk a little bit about that,
right.
Well, it's actually almost never true.
So a generics are not identical copies.
They are versions of brand name drugs and
the FDA recognizes that they're not identical
because they give a range, uh, that the generic
can fall into in terms of the dissolution
of the drug in the blood.
So under the best of circumstances, uh, it,
the generic is similar but not identical.
Um, they may have different active dick, different
additional ingredients, different time release
mechanism.
They're made in different factories, uh, avail,
dissolve differently in the body.
Uh, but where it really gets dangerous.
Uh, and what I document in my book bottle
of lies is the ways in which a generic drug
manufacturing plants on many of which operate
overseas are actually committing fraud and
submitting fake data to get approval from
the FDA to sell drugs.
Right.
So there's sort of two layers to this.
One is, is there even the expectation or belief
that the generic is in practical terms, the
same thing as the name brand drug.
Then separately from that, there's the question
of oversight and accuracy as to whether the
generic is even what it purports to be.
And it seems as though both of these are issues
that are happening at the same time.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean, the, the idea of the generic as a
version a and not an identical copy is accepted
and actually acceptable.
And for many, many drugs, uh, aversion is
fine, although there are some drugs were really
precise, dosing is required and those can
be a problem.
But the, I think the greater risk for American
consumers is that the FDA is not adequately
policing these manufacturing plants overseas.
And essentially accepting the data that these
companies are submitting as accurate a when
they are not.
And it's not always, I mean, so we can, there
are a number of criticisms of the FDA, many
of which I've made on this program.
But is this a limitation in terms of the standards
that are being applied to generics?
Is this something that the FDA is choosing
not to do, or is it something that it is,
at least in some cases unable to do?
Huh?
Well, I think the two are somewhat connected,
but basically the FDA is a agency that because
of globalization was suddenly required to
police manufacturing plants all over the world.
And it essentially acknowledges the difficulty
of this because for us, plants, when he inspects,
they just, the inspectors arrive on an unannounced
and stay as long as is needed.
But because of the complex logistics of overseas
inspections, the FDA announces that it's arriving
to these plants, gives them weeks and sometimes
months of advanced notice that they're coming.
So my investigation reveals a, they will send
in the plants, will send in data fabrication
teams to alter documents, invent documents,
uh, backdate documents and these are all,
you know, quality data quality documents that
speak to, uh, whether the drug is bio equivalent,
whether it's got impurities in it or not.
Um, all kinds of issues that are critical
to have the drug functions.
When we think about this, there might be people
depending on their health circumstances, who
here is talking about this and they go to
Advil versus the cvs generic equivalent for
example.
But there are other people who may be in situations
where they are actually using generic alternatives
to very, very expensive name brand drugs depending
on the, the medical conditions that they may
have.
Does your investigation suggests that the
same issues exist to the same degree with
both the Advil generics and the really expensive
drugs for, for less common conditions?
Or is it more one versus the other?
It's actually both.
So, just to give you an example in the book,
I follow these cardiologists from the Cleveland
Clinic who realize that when their patients
were getting switched to certain generics,
um, they were initially stable and then they
were no longer stable and even, uh, they found
that heart transplant patients were suffering
organ rejection when they were switched to
certain Indian generics.
So there is a, uh, that's generic drugs that
were manufactured in India.
Um, so there's, you know, life threatening
dangers here.
Um, my book focuses less on over the counter
drugs, but you know, what consumers should
know is that the drug store brands say Duane
Reed, cvs, the drug store chains are contracting
with the lowest cost Indian manufacturers
to make those over the counter drugs.
And those plants are really, uh, audited and
inspected infrequently.
So there is a quality issue there as well.
So, I mean, having dug into this and investigated
it for the period of time that you did to,
to write the book is your takeaway that there's
just too much risk with any generic and that
patients should be doing everything they can
to get their insurance to cover the name brand.
Because we'll talk about the sort of practical
limitations of that.
I mean, are you, are you, did you come away
that concerned where you would just want the
name brand of any drug that you're taking?
Um, I would say two things about that.
I came away extremely concerned and I interviewed
plenty of FDA investigators who themselves
would not take the drugs made in the plants
that they were inspecting.
Hmm.
Uh, but that said, I also recognize cost is
a serious reality and it is for me as well.
So, um, what I do is I often ask my pharmacist
to switch from one generic, which I don't
trust to another generic made by a different
company that I might trust more.
That's it.
Yeah.
It's knowable.
Which brands, generics are, are more or less
is trustworthy even the right word?
Hmm.
Um, it is a knowable thing.
Now the problem is do you have to be an investigative
journalist who's looked into this for 10 years
to know it in order to help consumers, I have
put information on my website, which is Catherine
even.com.
Uh, and so there is information about steps
that they can take to try to figure out, um,
whether they're generic is trustworthy or
not and what the options are if they determine
that they want to switch.
Um, you know, it is a bit of a maze.
I'm not going to be, you know, kind of sugarcoat
that.
I think what's really needed is congressional
action here to fix the problems that I've
exposed.
But in lieu of that, I think there are certain
steps that consumers can take.
There's also something called an authorized
generic.
So that is a generic where the brand company
has made a contract with a generic company
handed over it's recipe.
Um, and the generic company is making the
drug under a contract so it's actually closer
to the brand.
And sometimes those authorized generics are
actually manufactured in the very same plants
as the brand name drug.
What, what?
You know a lot of people who have dealt with
insurance companies, no, is that depending
on the coverage that you have and depending
on where you get your insurance, whether an
individual marketplace, as a self employed
person or through a work connected insurance
plan, there are all sorts of complex rules
about what your insurance will or will not
cover when it comes to prescription medications.
And doctors certainly have the ability to
put no substitution on prescriptions, which
collectively tells the pharmacy that a named
brand is what should be provided.
But that does not guarantee that runs health
insurance is going to cover the name brand
at the same price that the generic would be
covered.
So this is, I mean this is really complicated
stuff, particularly for people who, who require
medications that are extremely,
yeah, absolutely.
This is not simple and you're quite right
that even with the do not substitute, there's
no guarantee that the insurance company will
cover a brand when a generic is available.
Can you talk a little bit about, I mean obviously
there are a number of different types of concerns
there.
There's straight up safety concerns, right?
Upside of Beck's that one could experience
experienced adverse reactions.
There's also the concern of just a drug that
in June it's generic version is less potent
or may not achieve the same results as the
name brand.
How would you sort of put percentages on those
two concerns and others that may exist as
a general rule?
When we talk about ways in which the generics
may be suboptimal?
Right?
So I don't know that I can offer percentages.
What I can say is that even if the generics
are fine, there is an issue for what are called
narrow therapeutic index drugs.
And so those are drugs that require really
precise dosing and the doctors who prescribed
those, so it's cardiologists, psychiatrists,
endocrinologist, they are, um, familiar with
this as a problem and they have raised questions
about whether the FDA standards, um, are narrow
enough to make, to ensure that the generics
are clinically equivalent to the brand.
So that's like in one basket of concerns.
Um, unfortunately with this other basket,
um, there is really widespread fraud in the
overseas manufacturing plants that are making
the majority of our generics.
So just as an example, um, I feature in the
book an Fda investigator named Peter Baker
who became exceptionally good at finding data
fraud in these plants.
And over five years he investigated 86 plants
in India and China and found some element
of data fraud or data deception in about four
fifths of those plants.
So a stunning number.
Yeah, it really is.
Yeah, absolutely.
So, I mean, these are, these are plants that
are doing everything from using the brand
name drugs, uh, to run tests and take that
data and submit it to the FDA as though it
was their own data from their own drugs.
So completely supplanting the data, inventing
documents and steaming them in rooms overnight
to make them look old.
Um, you know, completely just discarding critical
manufacturing documents where FDA investigators
have dug them out of dumpsters when documents
are supposed to be retained.
So, you know, these are really, um, major
lapses in what are called good manufacturing
practices that these plants have to follow.
I mean, some plants have, even when you have
a sterile manufacturing plant, and that's
very serious, they have to follow a sort of
a septic regulations.
Um, they have literally invented there sterility
data.
They're supposed to test air water surfaces
to make sure they're free of microbial contaminants
and they've just invented that data.
They're not really running the tests.
Uh, so that's the kind of things that are
going on in these plants.
Absolutely, absolutely stunning.
Um, make sure to check out Katherine's book,
bottle of lies, the inside story of the generic
drug.
Boom.
We have been speaking with the book's author,
Katherine Eban.
Yeah.
Who is an investigative journalist and Fortune
magazine contributor.
Katherine, so great to talk to you about this.
Great to talk to you.
Thank you so much.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com